[Musique]
avec anthony st léger bonsoir entêtement
soir audrey avant sur atos confrontée
elle aussi à une hausse des
contaminations coville 19 l'italie qui a
rendu mercredi la vaccination
obligatoire pour les plus de 50 ans est
un terreau fertile pour les thèses
complotistes liés à la pandémie et on va
en voir un exemple aujourd'hui ces
dernières semaines plusieurs montages
circulent à nouveau sur les réseaux
sociaux regardez cette photo de
cercueils alignés alors vous avez en eau
celle ci donc qui mentionne lampedusa à
2013 et puis celle ci en bas la même
mais dans une autre couleur bergamo 2020
cette juxtaposition de photos elles
circulent tantôt dans des publications
en anglais en français ou en italien et
les légendes affirme à chaque fois que
la photo du bas a été mal utilisées en
l'occurrence pour montrer à tort des
patients et des victimes en l'occurrence
du coco vide 19 et les commentaires vous
le voyez de développer la même idée
l'idée que le virus serait une invention
que la pandémie est une exagération
on a même ici dans cette publication
facebook cette idée que dans cette
opération qu'ovide tout est faux et que
c'est ce type de photos qui auraient
contribué à la frénésie du verrouillage
à référence évidemment aux différents
confinement mais pourquoi est ce qu'il y
à confusion entre ces deux images alors
l'une des photos mentionne à bergamo
joue le disait bergamo comme bergame en
fait j'y vois là ça bergame en français
cette ville du nord de l'italie c'est là
une référence en fait au documentaire de
simone aventura les sept jours de
bergame un documentaire dont la
réalisatrice a publié la bande annonce
sur son compte facebook c'était le 23
août dernier alors pourquoi cette
référence parce que la photo du bas et
bien c'est bien une capture d'écran
faite à partir de ce documentaire elle
est présente à la 46e secondes
précisément ce documentaire rapidement
il a été présenté à la mostra de venise
2021 il porte sur les décès provoqués
par locaux vides 19 dans cette ville
précisément de bergame en mars 2020
pourquoi parce que lors de cette
première vague est bien à cette ville
comme beaucoup a été durement frappé
pour vous donner une idée parce que les
services mortuaires était tout
simplement dépassée par cette vague eh
bien ils ne pouvaient pas faire face à
l'afflux de mort et ce sont des camions
militaires qui ont pris le relais pour
transporter les cercueils dans d'autres
villes d'italie parfois en pleine nuit
voilà pour la petite parenthèse donc
cette image provient bien du
documentaire sauf que elle a été
faussement associés aux morts du coffee
19 en effet il ya une erreur dans le
documentaire erreur avéré puisque elle a
été corrigé par la suite par la
réalisatrice des lendemains dans sa
version facebook de la bande annonce
qu'elle avait publiées sur facebook
originalement
et elle a été remplacée par ce plan que
l'on voit ici celui d'une mort donc à
bergame on y est bien en pleine crise
sanitaire et la vidéo a été supprimée
sur youtube par la suite et d'où vient
enfin de compte l'image originale des
cercueils et bien là c'est une rapide de
recherche d'image inversé comme on est
habitué maintenant via l'outil de
vérification une vide par exemple qui
nous donne la réponse elle nous ramène
en octobre 2013 le 5 plus précisément et
en est à lampedusa comme le mentionnait
la photo du haut vous en rappelez et ce
cliché il a été pris par le photographe
italien alberto pizzoli et ses cercueils
ce sont ceux de migrants morts le 3
octobre 2013 au large de l'île de
lampedusa quand on pense à lampedusa
malheureusement on pense beaucoup à
l'immigration et surtout au drame que
cela suscite et en l'occurrence il
s'agit de corps repêchés lors d'un
naufrage au naufrage qui a causé la mort
de plus de 360 personnes on en parlait à
l'époque déjà sur france 24 et depuis
mai 2000 20 depuis cette première vague
du coc vide et bien cette erreur entre
les deux photos elle donne du grain à
moudre aux complotistes s'en délecte en
forcément pour accréditer la thèse que
cette pandémie n'est que manipulation et
notamment que les chiffres liés au décès
sont exagérées alors oui il ya eu erreur
mais cette erreur ne permet pas pour
autant de remettre en cause la réalité
de l'épidémie merci beaucoup anthony
sent léger pour ce décryptage à cette
erreur malencontreuse on skie